what i'm saying is don't settle don't
live lives of complacency because there
is so much out there for us we all have
the right to live incredibly fulfilled
incredibly passionate incredibly joyful
lives where you are psyched it's monday
morning
benjamin welcome back to the show
thanks chris good to be here appreciate
it i want to start with a quote from
your instagram
it is impossible to live without failing
at something unless you live so
cautiously that you might as well have
not lived at all in which case you fail
by default that's a jk rowling quote
what's that mean to you
uh
so if you
if you
you can play it safe right you can play
it so safe in life that
um there are no risks
you know it's basically it's think of
the parallel to
exercise
you can live such a life that you will
not get hurt exercising
what that looks like is sitting on the
couch all day long
so there is an inherent risk that you
will get hurt the moment you do any form
of exercise you're going to try and get
shape in any way shape or form
and that's the parallel to life if you
are going to try to do anything
meaningful in your life there is an
inherent risk that you will not succeed
that should not stop you because if you
don't try you're you're failing by
default you're you're not
going to
um live a life of any sort of
meaningfulness fulfillment or impact on
anybody else and that's kind of my
measure of success is
is your life meaningful fulfilled and
have an impact on other people so get
out there and go do it
it seems to me that you make quite
prudent decisions do you have to push
yourself to take risks sometimes
yeah i think that uh so i'm an
entrepreneur so uh i think i'm i'm
i'm not quite as risk averse as many
other people but
you know i it's probably built into be
on being an entrepreneur i think it's
probably built into my dna a little bit
that i want i'm so
um
so driven to live a a life that i'm
proud of so driven to live a life of
meaning and uh joy and happiness and
um i don't want to put that off for
anything so because of that i think i'm
willing to take more risks along the way
case in point um when
after
i'm graduating from college university
um i got a really secure job doing
finance and
um i wasn't feeling fulfilled so i took
the big massive risk and left the
corporate ladder the security of the
paycheck and this really nice
um
career path
and i didn't know what i was going to do
but i just moved out to become a ski bum
for a year to try to figure it out
because to me
the risk of not living a life to its
fullest meaning
is
essentially a nightmare it's hell on
earth like living it not
on your terms not taking control and not
doing something that you want to do
is
um
is not the way i want to go about things
so because that i think that's
i don't even when i'm making those
decisions i don't necessarily saying
like whoa this can be really risky
it's just
is the alternative complacency and if
there are terms of complacency i'm out
and i want the other path
what do you say to people that need that
bit more of a push that maybe feel a
little bit unsatisfied with where
they're at but are struggling to take
action well i don't i don't say it to
them because it's their choice to make
and i'm not here to say
that the risk is worth the effort
because everyone has a different
um
risk aversion and risk
um willingness scale
and
what i say is um like there are certain
plenty of things that i don't want to do
like i you know
i don't want to go
free solo up el capitan like that's not
that's too risky for me
but for somebody else that might be
totally within their wheelhouse so for
me to put my value system on what is
risky and what is not um i'm not here to
do that so if somebody's like should i
make the leap should i make the jump
that's something that you got to listen
to and when i say listen to it's not a
matter of weighing out the pros and cons
on a piece of paper unless you know one
side here's all the things that would go
right here's all things that could go
wrong
to me it's
listen to your guts
because your gut has
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
years of evolutionarily evolutionary
biology built into that dna that's
helping guide that decision
and if it feels not right in your guts
it probably isn't right
so
that's something that people i think can
come a little bit more in tune with is
what is there i think we're so
um
you know in today's world
influence to be logical beings that's
what you know we say like changes us
from the apes is like that we have the
prefrontal cortex we can think we're the
only animals that can think about our
thoughts whereas everyone else has the
lizard brain the amygdala and we kind of
they operate on instinct i think we've
lost a little bit of instinct and we try
to
rationalize everything and i think that
the gut
is the thing that can
uh that should guide more decision
making along the way if what we're truly
looking for is to live
meaningful impactful lives dude i've
been thinking about this so much
recently the the fact that
we pray at the altar of cognitive
horsepower so much right we just believe
that we can wrangle the world around us
through just sheer cerebral weight right
here's a story so um halfway through
last year i got put on really really
boring normal medication and i didn't
realize but when the doctor said you
need to up the dose
i didn't know that it was an
anticholinergic do you know what that is
no okay so choline is one of the
neurotransmitters that makes your brain
work basically when you take nootropics
many of them have choline in them and
over a little bit of time my thoughts
ended up being super muddy like i pride
myself on having agile thoughts right
i'm a podcaster my that's my money i
need to be able to think quickly what's
in my head needs to come out of my mouth
one day i was out for a walk and it took
me 90 seconds to remember a town that
i've been to 10 times like to remember
the name of it i'm thinking okay
there's a there's some sort of a problem
here and it makes you start to doubt and
and feel
very
conscious of the fact that you don't
have the ability to fix the problems the
same way
and then i realized what it was
dropped the dose everything was fine
totally reversible
but what i felt for a small amount of
time was basically like
kind of like a dementia type situation
just a restriction in my processing
ability and i spoke to a friend whose
dad had dementia and he said
this illness has taken everything from
me it's even taken myself
what he means by that is
when we are people that rely on our
brains to get us out of problems like i
know that no matter what the situation
is that i get myself into i can probably
think my way to a solution that will get
myself out of it and there's something
that's so
brutal
about
degenerating your ability to think
because it's killing your ability to fix
the problems not just giving you
problems as
well yeah i think so that is i mean
so the cognitive thinking the thinking
brain the problem solving that is what
i don't want to diminish that at all
because that's what gave us the light
bulb it's why we're able to talk across
an ocean it gave us everything that we
have as human beings so it's the it is
the most powerful thing that we have
i just believe that we've we've become
too reliant on it and we're not and
because that we can rationalize
everything away for logical reasons i
can't quit my job because x y z and a b
and c it makes no sense to quit my
meanwhile
we live unfulfilled lives because we're
not willing to take them step forward
and do something that your gut is
screaming at you going let's go be happy
let's find joy let's go for a walk in
nature i know you have those 19 emails
you need to respond to but
this is
you know it's
you know i've been reading a lot about
um
marketing recently and
it's
it's
we run our businesses this way we run
our businesses based off because you can
find any data and we run we we dive into
the data
yet
we can't logically explain why
advertisements with animals in them do
better than advertisements that don't
and we don't need to respond we don't
need to rationalize we don't need to
figure out everything logically some
things are just
magic right some things are just built
so far into our biology as human beings
that we're not going to be able to
figure it out and put it on a
spreadsheet not everything is ex you
know able to
fit into an excel document some things
are literally just
feel and emotions and as much as we you
know goes back to like the simon cynic
thing is people don't buy what you do
they they buy why you do it and
that goes right down to the root of
everything well forget about
all of this you know we started this
with this risk
thing
um
don't try to weigh and measure it just
listen to your gut
and this is
right down to like people that are
trying to figure out like should i stay
with my partner or not
you know i'm not fulfilled in my
relationships should i stay with my and
you go like well i should because
um
that's how i create uh
you know some sort of steadiness in my
life whether it's financial or routine
or
it's what what will my friends and
family think or what will my religious
group think or
what would the alternative be is it
being alone and all these things and
this is the reason people settle and
become complacent and they end up living
with a non-supportive what you know wife
or husband it is either in my opinion it
is either
you live in an incredibly
passionate
supportive trusting relationship
or you don't have a relationship there
is no middle it's to me it is binary
where people go like well it's okay
because you know if i if i move out it's
gonna be really tough to
um support myself and my kids and i
won't see my kids as much and we'll stay
together for the kids and
this is why people live you know are
afraid
to take the leap to leave their job to
leave their spouse i'm not and i'm not
on i'm not here you know promoting like
people go quit your jobs go to get
divorced what i'm saying is don't settle
don't live lives of complacency because
there is so much out there for us we are
all
we all have the right to live incredibly
fulfilled incredibly passionate
incredibly joyful lives where you are
psyched it's monday morning where you
are psyched that you're in quarantine
with your family where you are psyched
that you get to do what you do every
single day and if something doesn't line
up that way don't put it off this is
your life
no one is going to come and change it
for you i think that we all kind of wait
for because what we grew up with our
entire lives
mom and dad will do this then teachers
will do this then society tells us to do
this and then it's all pre-programmed
for us and by the time we have control
over our lives as functioning adults in
society we're programmed we're
programmed to follow the script and we
go well the script is going to change
eventually and then the next thing that
people look forward to is retirement and
by the time you're in retirement you
think that that's where you're going to
kick it that's where you're going to be
in the hammock with the the the
drink with the umbrella in it and be
able to have fun and by that time you've
given up your passions you've given up
your hobbies you haven't lived a life
that you want to and you hope that
you're going to finally get there and
it's not there for you
don't
wait like take the risks to make it
happen today
no one's coming to do it for you
at all absolutely not
you rely a lot on being procedural with
your efforts you've got this awareness
intention action framework that you
follow and a lot of people that are
listening are going to be intentional
actors as well personal development
self-development thinking about their
work throughout the day
how do you balance being intentional
with trying to have that intuitive sense
come in as well do you feel attention
all that no i think it's all it's one of
the same and it's self-awareness
so
um
everything to me starts with awareness
whether you're trying to make changes in
your life or you're trying to figure out
your strengths and weaknesses you're
trying to figure out what you um how to
become happy
it literally all so let's take that one
let's we're trying to become happy
because i think that truly is
the shared purpose across humanity we
can call it what we want
interchange that word for happy for
enlightened call it finding god call it
pure consciousness
call it whatever you want to that's what
we all have as a shared purpose call it
evolution right the evolution of our of
ourselves mind body and spirit that's
what we all have as a shared common
purpose now
everyone has their own unique purposes
as well which is their talents and it
changes based off of opportunities and
where you are in your life but that
shared purpose of happiness
that's
that level of awareness just of that
like knowing that that's what we should
all be
chasing that's what we all are looking
for now if that's the case what are the
things that make me happy and it's a
simple exercise is like get out a piece
of paper and i do it on my notes on my
phone i do this every so often is make a
running list that you can cross off and
add to of the things that make you happy
and what you'll find is i'm not talking
like in the moment i'm not talking about
like getting high i'm not talking like
um you know watching funny movies
although that might make the list but
what you'll find is
things that
make you happy might not make you happy
in the moments but they do eventually
and my list involves things like you
would expect um you know i like
exercising it makes me feel good i like
being in nature i like
um i but i also like building things i
like working with teams i like leading
people i like being creative i like
thinking about the future i like
um
breaking things down into frameworks i
like doing yard work like and you create
these lists and then what you do is you
become what you're what you're saying
before then you create intentionality
around creating those moments
no one's coming to do those things for
you if you find fulfillment and joy and
happiness
being going for nature walks then
schedule those in
and schedule it in the way you would
schedule in a dentist appointment where
when it comes you don't push it off for
something else it's the thing that's so
now we have the awareness of truly aware
of what's going to make me happy the
intentionality of this is going to
happen if i don't do this it's not going
and then the the action like if you we
can talk about all we want and talking
about it does make me feel good just
like everyone talking about it but
that's the trap
because
you talking about your goals
actually elicits the same dopamine as
actually
doing your goals so it's it's a trick
and we have to recognize that
it's the actual doing that moves us
forward it is truly not until we take
the steps that we go anywhere so that's
why the that three-step process of
awareness intentionality and action
is kind of that's you know the the three
pillars that i think move people towards
that
you know you fill in the blank finding
god
pure consciousness
um enlightenment or just joy like joy in
their lives and i if we don't operate in
that
circular fashion of constant
flywheel of awareness intention action
awareness because when you take action
you get greater levels of awareness
did this truly help me move me towards
my goals or not and then you move and
you iterate it's the lean startup model
it's the build measure learn right let's
take action let's just build it we have
to wait for perfect let's jump
grow wings on the way down
learn iterate and make adjustments along
the way if you keep on that flywheel
eventually you'll get to and it's not
going to happen immediately but
eventually you get closer and closer to
that end state and you enjoy the process
along the way because you're making the
adjustments
with intentionality not just getting
pushed by anybody else or society
i don't know what the next book plan is
but i think that that should be one of
the ones before you hang up the writing
pen i think that that
that framework is is worthy of a book
noted good uh talking about big risks
news recently when dave castro was let
go by crossfit hq although he might not
be technically a leader he's definitely
a big figurehead in the sport in a lot
of people's eyes what were your thoughts
on that
uh i so the first one was surprise i
actually um i was coaching the 5 30 a.m
class at the gym and i came in and
started coaching and um the members that
my members actually told me
um because i hadn't checked social or
anything like that so my first reaction
was surprise and i i remember it um and
i was surprised mostly because
i thought if it was gonna happen it
would have happened right as new
leadership comes in
um the easiest thing to do is to rip off
band-aids clean household at once yeah
just clean house and they did that right
they they made a lot of shifts and a lot
of changes um but dave was there so that
was my initial reaction but then with a
little bit of hindsight and a little bit
more perspective a little thought
um
the timing of the change actually does
make sense
so if we remember back when rosa took
over for glassman that was um
it was late spring or early summer
somewhere in there and the games were
looming right the games were around the
corner and it was in the midst of a
pandemic so this is where they had to
scrape together a completely new format
where they did an online qualifier and
they invited five guys and five girls to
aromas california
so to do that
with complete new leadership on the game
side
would have been um
probably too risk and i think it was the
smart move for eric to rosa not to make
that move
so then
it puts us into that next season and i
think that you know
from
there's a little bit of stability now so
it actually makes sense from a timing
perspective in my in my view um
it was not that the ship has kind of
like settled a little bit so a little
bit of rocking can be withstood
and the timing does seem to make sense
now so
while it was initial shock because i
thought it would have happened
it's that dissipated fairly quickly
um
because
here's my personal opinion on it i think
dave did a really good job running the
games i think from an organizational
standpoint and from a program standpoint
the games are a phenomenal test and a
terrific showcase
they would not i don't think they would
be what they are without dave castro
um but i can see
why eric might think that a change is
necessary to get the sport to where he
wants it to go
um
why is that
um dave is polarizing
i mean um
dave wore shirts that said unapologetic
that was his tagline
it's like so unapologetic means don't
take ownership in my mind
that's polarizing now
um dave would swear on tv so to get to
the next level right to get to the
um
um the next place i think it
it could i'm not saying
i'm i'm not i don't have enough inner
workings knowledge of the
of how
it shakes up
but i can understand the reasons for it
um you know
strangely enough
you know i've i've known dave for a
fairly long time and i think that the
last two games the one in aromas with
five people five guys five girls and the
last one
um
dave did as good a job as he's ever done
from a athlete relations standpoint
so i actually didn't see this coming
because
again i if it was going to happen i
thought it was going to happen and dave
did a
really good job of of being a better
leader i would say
i saw the growth of him as a leader over
the last two years so
i i was surprised because i saw it
moving in the right direction i've
definitely seen dave be more
cantankerous in the past than he has
done recently yeah it's um
it's so interesting there's a lot been
conversations in our gym
about this and i think the polarizing
nature of dave
has trickled down to people as well
there seems to be sort of broadly two
camps of people people that can't
believe that he's gone and it's an
absolute travesty and people
it was overdue
dave you know it doesn't fit the new
vision that we have for crossfit now one
of the things that's interesting is
it depends on what eric's uh vision i
think for the sport is long term whether
or not you want to be on espn whether or
not you want to be able to commercialize
more whether or not you want to have
that increasingly professional sort of
stance
but there is still a huge huge group of
people in crossfit that like the
anti-marketing movement the underground
fitness mentality and i think that you
know uh when
greg went
that was
that was a
a little bit of a peer into a culture
that maybe hadn't caught up with the
modern era quite so much and you see you
know some of the media team went as well
they were some of the more outspoken
guys as well okay then they've gone and
castro kind of was a little bit like
well
what the [ __ ] that guy doing there
like how's he how's he still there but
then you think well he's a programming
genius some of the work out think about
uh was it
20.1 the wall was that wall walks yep
that workout is one of the smartest
workouts like he destroyed top level
athletes with a wall that absolutely
destroyed them and i i think that his
programming's beautiful he was the third
ever podcast that i did on this show
three four years ago at the 18.0
announcement and um he's a polarizing
figure but he gave the sport character
there's an element of that edge to him
and i think that you're probably right
it's a case of
where does crossfit where does eric want
crossfit to be long term
so i can
i can give uh my two cents into that
because i've had conversations with eric
and he's told me that now
this might be this might have changed
because i had this conversation as eric
first came in so i had a couple
conversations with him in his first
weeks on the job um
and
his view so
here's
glassman was not a fan of the crossfit
games he actually think it clouded the
vision of what crossfit was supposed to
be
eric is a huge fan of the crossfit games
like a fan boy like he loves it he
competes in it himself he's ver he loves
it
eric whereas greg saw it as a sideshow
and at best and more realistically
probably a a massive distraction
eric sees it as a avenue for a huge part
of the growth of crossfit as a whole
these athletes represent the pinnacle of
what we can all aspire to be
and he's looking to have a viewership of
a hundred million people
that's a massive number do you know what
it is currently
uh i would guess it's in the
neighborhood of single-digit millions
so
but even if it's 10 million that's a 10x
growth
that puts it on par with like so i think
the super bowl gets like 300 million or
something like that so that gets on par
with like
normal nfl playoff type things it puts
it
above ufc like it's a huge
huge number
and
he's he's used ufc as a parallel for the
sport so
in order for that to happen and then you
start to realize
what
his responsibilities are
whereas glassman's responsibilities
were to the
legacy of
crossfit the methodology the methodology
that's what his responsibilities were
and to
forge elite fitness
and
to get people off the carbs and off the
couch that's basically what he was his
missions and then he took that to like
this
revolutionary and um let's go fight big
soda and those type of things and let's
try to change the world
eric's
so eric didn't buy crossfit i think
that's a misnomer
eric
headed up a group that he got a bunch of
people to invest
in crossfit
so he's responsible
for
their investments like anybody would
once you get backed by
private equity
you have to you're responsible for so he
has to grow this thing
and
i think that that probably is at the
heart of the dave thing as much as
anything
um dave might have been part of the old
guard i don't know this now i'm
speculating but dave might have been
part of the old guard and like this the
way we're gonna do it
um or
the polarizing aspect of it didn't allow
for enough um upside swing of growth
potential yeah so
they might need to get somebody that is
willing to completely sit in the
background
again speculation completely not have
and let a um somebody else be the face
of this thing
whether it's whether it's the
whether it's the athlete you know roger
goodell is not the face of the nfl
you know and even dana white is stepping
back as the face of ufc and letting the
athletes be them or you have a true
personality come in and be the face of
it you know like
a rory mckernon or a patcher word or
something like that somebody that you
know
um
again this is me speculating in my
opinions i'd have said that dave could
have filled that dana roll quite nicely
i think he's got a little bit of edge
he's got the reputability from having
been there from the very very beginning
you see somebody like dana that is a
very he's the fight maker right or
that's one of his main roles and he's a
common thread that ties together very
very early days with current days and
he's been there through the reebok buy
out then venom buy out and
fight is coming and going and
acquisitions and stuff like that and it
is nice i think to have that you know
it's eric's decision or whatever and
it'll be interesting to see what happens
as someone who doesn't have their money
um
based on the uh what dave decides to say
on a microphone or the t-shirts that he
wears or the hairdo that he turns up
with
i would have much preferred to see
dave castro continue to be the guy that
programs the games and he's there
announcing and doing all of that stuff
uh however from a business perspective i
can see why that wouldn't work and it'll
be interesting to see whether or not
going
business first leads to a better
experience down the road or whether um
sticking to
the old school core principles would
have been a more effective strategy but
i guess yeah time will tell with time
uh you said recently talking about
leadership and stuff like that you said
that you weren't a born leader
how so
oh
um
so
i i actually when i was younger i would
take personality tests um it would come
up that i was a phenomenal follower give
me directions tell me what to do and i
go off marching and do it and
do a pretty good job of it that's
um transformed
um as as i've gotten older so that's the
first piece the second piece is i'm
extremely introverted still am i'd much
rather be a
a wallflower at a party than um
the center of attention even talking to
people at all honestly i'd rather just
listen
um
you know it in terms of like if you
define extroverts and introverts if um
being around other people um gives you
energy or takes energy away from you
being around other people takes energy
away from me i'd rather be
creating stuff on my own
so it's effort it's a lot of effort for
me to
try to have conversations and try to
communicate with people and hold people
to certain levels of standards and
expectations and share the vision and
create common threads throughout an
organization or teams
but i've learned to
honestly being a coach has kind of
helped transform that a little bit
because when you're a coach that's the
job the coach's job is to be the leader
of an individual or a team
so it's allowed me to
um you know
grow my wings a little bit um as i've
gone through this process but
my natural inclination is
um
probably not leader first it's something
that i've
uh struggled with and and frankly when i
started put myself in a leadership
position as an entrepreneur it was
something i was
pretty poor at and i think that even
today you know 15 to 20 years into this
journey
um i'm mediocre at like it's something
that i'm continuing to try to
learn but as we talked about before
that self-awareness is the big
the big thing we need to start with
and then we create some intention take
actions beyond that but you know if um
when there is a
crisis i'm not the guy that's like let's
go do it charge into the fray let's go
take it's like
dang
oh man this is gonna require a lot like
that's that's my
that's my
into it that's my gut that's who i am as
a person you know i
avoid conflicts massively i'd much
rather have people like me than kind of
like jump into it it's a lot of work for
me to
have
tactful conflict resolution it's a lot
of work for me to
pick up the phone and have a phone call
it's so much easier for me to sit on the
sidelines and just hope it all works out
i've learned that's not the best
have you just tumbled into this position
then because all of these things are
reasons why you should absolutely suck
at doing yes absolutely your job you
shouldn't be the leader of a team you
shouldn't be the leader of a business
you shouldn't have an online platform
that you know thousands and thousands of
people follow and trying to make the
best crossfit or like fitness gym in the
world and stuff like how the [ __ ] did
you get here
um
i stumbled into it yeah
yeah
um
i
opened up a gym because i was super
passionate about
fitness as a means to get people to
become the best versions of themselves
you know if we are that's that same
shared purpose we all have so here's i
believe that
our training methodology training really
hard
is as worthy a means to in to
enlightenment as anything that's ever
existed meaning
people can choose any one of these tools
whether it's meditating
journaling
going to church
a.a uh it's like dance music like art
like all of those things are ways for
people to
find pure consciousness to find
themselves and find joy to find
awareness about self-awareness about who
they are
i believe that
hard training not
um jazz or size
but what we do because what we do the
greatest adaptation and yeah we get
ripped and you get lean and you lower
triglycerides and you
increase your longevity and your
functionality the biggest adaptation is
between the ears you like you you're
you're a different
human being
in your brain from having experienced
this path
and that's what i believe from day one
that's why i wanted to open up a gym
was because i believed i could help
change people from the inside out to
leave more purpose
driven lives
and when i opened up a gym
i was
even before that i was a personal
trainer and doing it from a personal
training standpoint that's kind of my
sweet spot one-on-one
build a relationship and we can do that
and then from there
things kind of went really well
and i got a little following and it made
sense to open up a gym so i open up a
gym and then it becomes this thing where
okay now this is going well and we need
to hire coaches
and that's where the thing starts once
you have to lead other employees the
thing changes and then we
created a team that competed at the
crossfit games
and okay now you have to lead that team
and we win the crossfit games oh my gosh
now people want to follow you so you
create an online platform and
that starts to snowball and then it
creates turns into a revenue stream and
now you have a business underneath you
so
yeah it was um
i wouldn't say reluctantly because i've
enjoyed all the steps
but it was um organically it just kind
of i didn't i didn't seek out a
leadership position and
um
it it doesn't it's not part of who i am
at on a on a molecular level it seems
like a a career
a series of stumbling down a set of
stairs and at each step that you've
arrived at it's just been another
challenge that you've needed to do and
it's like well i'm the guy it looks like
i'm the guy i much prefer that sort of a
story when it comes to
entrepreneurialism
athleticism building a team creating an
organization or a movement or a culture
or a podcast or whatever it is i much
prefer that sort of story because i
think that on average
far more people end up in positions like
that by following their passion not
really being able to predict the future
that much maybe just kind of
knowing one or two steps in front of
them and then before they know it they
look back after five or ten years and go
holy [ __ ] look at all of this stuff that
we've built and
it creates anxiety this sort of ambient
anxiety amongst people that don't have a
plan
when they don't have a plan
and they think oh well look the the what
ben got to the stage with the online and
the gym and the team and the crossfit
games and the stuff he must have laid
all out and you go you can get through
this by just doing your best as
challenges arise and taking
opportunities as they arise and then in
retrospect anybody can piece together
some [ __ ] story about how i knew it
was going to be this and i the vision
with originally started off with the
personal training and i knew at that
moment i was going to take a team to the
crossfit no horseshit like the vast vast
vast majority of people stumble into
their success like falling down a set of
stairs
there's a dichotomy with that though
because on a personal level
yes and sort of and then once you have a
team
no
so here's what i mean by that
is from a personal level i think it
really helps to have
a vision
of what it is you're chasing
but it doesn't need
this that you don't have to have the
steps built out
you can just have the north star
right and the north star there's a
reason it's a north star because you can
purposely go off track when a plane
leaves new york city headed for san
francisco it's off track 99 of the time
it can be
tens and dozens and dozens of miles off
track
but as you get closer and closer it gets
more narrow and narrow and narrower and
certainly when you go to landing time
you want to be right on the button
and that's much like starting a business
when i started a business i didn't know
what i was trying to create i couldn't
have told you we're gonna have comp
train and we're gonna have um you know
six different gyms around but i knew
what i wanted this gets back to what we
originally started the conversation with
i knew what i wanted from a feel i knew
what the feeling i wanted was
and that is
when
we get done running a class at our gym i
don't want people to leave
that was the feeling and if we create
this place
where people feel like once they leave
they're gonna have this fomo this fear
of missing out
this is truly the best hour of their day
and they don't want to end so when the
workout ends they're hanging out
then we've created a transformational
experience for them
now transformational is the opposite of
transactional
transactional is
um i pay you you pay me i provide a
service and then you we
we
we shake hands and it's over
most
businesses are transactional you hire
someone to paint your house they paint
your house you pay them it's gone
what i wanted to do was not be a
transactional coach
and a transactional coach if we're
coaching basketball they teach you how
to do
um a triangle offense run a full court
press how to
square up your shoulders when you shoot
a basketball and how to defend a pick
and roll and when you're done playing
basketball
they haven't done much for you
whereas a transactional coach
makes you a better person
they teach you discipline they teach you
how to work through adversities they
teach you how to be more humble and a
better teammate
and what i wanted to do was to create a
business that was not transactional but
transformative
that changed people so when they were no
longer a part of our business whether
that was once they went home and they
spent the other 23 hours of their day
they were different people
or after they moved out of the state and
they were no longer able to come to our
gym they were different people for
having experienced our services
i knew from day one that i wanted that
and the ability to as then a leader to
share that
vision is a necessity you have to be
able to share that with your team
if you don't have that aspect of what
we're trying to create
you're at a loss because we are default
you're going to default to
making sure that the things on the
scoreboard are happening because the
only thing you can do is say that the
measurables are in place
and that's what everyone's running their
businesses now because there's more data
than there's ever been so what people
are doing is they're going okay did we
make x number of calls did that lead to
x number of tran uh uh conversions did
those conversions lead to this many um
sale uh onboarding sessions do those
onboarding sessions lead to this much of
a churn rate does that lead to this much
of an average client lifetime value okay
let's spin that back up to what is our
customer acquisition cost average
lifetime value versus customer
acquisition costs here we go we're in
the positive let's pour more fuel on the
fire and they think that's how to run a
business
when it is except that's not the
totality of it
it has to start with me which what is
the vision for the feel
what we're trying to create because as
we said in the beginning
people do things based off of feel
not off of logic
we have we are still emotional beings
the example of that is the parable of
the elephant and the rider
the elephant represents the amygdala
brain the feelings and the emotions
whereas the rider is the calculator the
rider is the human being on top that
actually knows how to get from point a
to point b and the most efficient way to
do that
the rider is in control for part of the
time
except for
once the the amygdala kicks in which
happens in every single buying purchase
that's the reason people are staying
with your business or leaving it it's
not because of your
price it's not because of the it's
because this gut feeling that they have
and as a leaders we have to understand
that that gut
feeling thing is the most important
thing that we have
and that's why our
driving mantra for our team
is to build a tribe
build a tribe
by making dope [ __ ] that creates a
feeling
that's what we're trying to do
now what that what that and from there
is we find the opportunities that come
and present themselves to us and we
figure out if this is in line with what
we're trying to do is this dope is this
gonna help us build a tribe this is
gonna create a feeling if it's not gonna
do those things it's not create a
feeling it's it's transactional push it
to the side that's things like making
better bells and whistles and all this
other stuff instead of things that are
really gonna tug at heartstrings that to
me is the way you lead you lead from the
front from the beginning is create an
understanding of what is that we're
trying to create
not from a
5 000 users 10
churn
23 profitability and 10 growth
like
cool
cool
but let's tug at the real things that
move the needle which is the emotion
are you familiar with good heart's law
do you know what that is i'm not okay
that is exactly what you're describing
goodheart's law is an adage often stated
as when a measure becomes a target it
ceases to be a good measure it's named
after a british economist charles
goodhart who advanced the idea in 1975.
so
an example of that might be um
a target i want to achieve
is a measure i want to achieve to base a
target on is the number of email
subscribers that i get so i'm going to
maximize the number of email subscribers
the way i'm going to do that is i'm
going to say
put your email in here and i will send
you a million pounds
thousands of people submit their email
address but you don't give them a
million pounds you have achieved the
target that you wanted but what you've
actually what you genuinely meant was i
want people to willingly give me that
email address so that they are glad to
receive emails from me on a weekly basis
that was the feel that you wanted
when you're relying on good heart's law
when you're looking at a measure
becoming a target it ceases to be a good
measure
for sure so like a great example of that
is your churn rate right how many
members are leaving every month versus
how many did you start with at the
beginning of the month if you have a
thousand members 100 leave during the
month your turn raised 10 well obviously
let's lower the churn rate well if that
becomes you can actually hack it right
if you cut your price down to 10
you're more people are going to stay
because there's just it's but
to your point that wasn't the intention
the intention of churn is to get people
to want to stay
it's what it's what it's what einstein
said is that not
everything
that can be measured
matters
and not everything that matters can be
measured
and that's why we can't get caught up in
this data-driven world that we have and
i'm not saying data is not important use
every bit of it that you can
just don't put blinders on because it's
not the thing that only thing that
matters there are things that happen
that we can not rationalize
this is one of the problems with
dashboards for online businesses for
podcasts for youtube channels stuff like
that again with youtube you could
clickbait your way to maximizing views
retention
um but really what are you trying to
achieve do you want to sell your soul to
get to 500 000 subs well probably not
like you're going to arrive at the
subscriber number that you said was the
target and realized that actually it
wasn't the outcome that your intention
meant so yeah i think this this applies
to a lot of things right you know you
could get yourself to i want to look
good in the mirror okay
i'm going to run at 500 calories for the
next six months and dial myself down to
some ridiculous body fat level again
like yes i've achieved the thing that i
wanted but what did i really mean i
probably meant i want to look and feel
great and confident in my body i want to
feel powerful and mobile and fit and
strong and attractive and all that stuff
okay is the solution that i've got
oversimplified and if it's
oversimplified i haven't actually got
the outcome that i meant right
yeah this is
it kind of speaks to
brand building right so
in business
um brand building is a really popular
thing right now and people
um
are chasing white rabbits
and they think that brand building is
brand awareness
and brand awareness is not the key
measure it's brand
relevance
and resonance it's like what does it
mean and how relevant are you in that
person's life
and when you start to pull back that way
a little bit it's not just about
how many people can become aware you
know the top of the funnel awareness how
many how can we make that bigger
it becomes you get you start to
understand which to your point is like
let's put more banner ads let's do more
digital let's put more
you start to recognize that that's not
the means to the end what we're actually
trying to do is
get people to feel better about our
brand
and that happens through
the sum of everything that we do
every single thing that you do for your
podcast everything it matters
even the intangibles the way that your
the things that you can't measure right
which is
the tonality of which you speak
the beautiful accent that you have like
those can't be measured but those are
the things that drive the needle more
than anything else that can be measured
i'm not saying that i'm not poo pooing
because we have a scoreboard we have a
dashboard
i'm not saying uh being
ignorant to that but
don't use that as the sole way to make
decisions
are there any unique advantages that you
think you have as an introvert and as
someone who was a uh
not an unwilling leader but an unlikely
leader maybe um are there any advantages
that you think that you have from that
position there might be introverts that
are listening who have to lead a team or
be part of a team or take over decision
making at some point
is there a way that you look at that and
see it as an advantage at all
um
yeah i think that maybe i
i don't have to backtrack on my words as
much as like some of my outspoken
friends do
because they'll just like without any
filter system whatsoever just comes out
right so
that may be one and i think it's i'm
i try to be very intentional
um but this isn't an introvert thing
this is something i've learned along the
way
is early days in my in being a leader in
the business they usually call my team
used to call them ben bombs
right where they be chugging away doing
their thing working hard and i would
come in with this new idea this new
great thing i'd be like so excited and
pumped up to talk about it and be like
guys this is listen to this
and like
and not realizing
the ramifications that me kind of
leaving that grenade there would have
because
as the leader of the business when i say
hey guys this is so exciting they go
okay
this is where we're going and
as a person
that has lots of those thoughts i've
realized i've had to curtail that a bit
so this is kind of the opposite of like
the injury but
um being an introvert to me
i'm
in my head quite a bit
and i create the space purposefully
because it gives me energy and when i
create the space i have lots of thoughts
on how to improve the business on how to
uh move the needle on how people are
reacting to the business
of what i feel like the gut thing is
that's going to drive people forward um
that kind of like
as an introvert growing up and not being
the center of attention i would sit on
the fringe of the circles and look and
listen dude that's that's exactly what i
had in my head
and look and listen to the way that
words and body language and topics would
resonate with people in the group
and
um i think it gave me a little bit of
insight into a sensitivity to um
you know sort of like a uh you know an
eq type thing emotional
intelligence sort of thing
um
i think also maybe even more so than the
um
lack of willingness to be loud in front
of people
was
my the way i went through school and
being dyslexic
and being dyslexic
i had to find workarounds they liked
like
solutions weren't necessarily school and
learning wasn't easy for me
and because of that
when i would read
i had to read so slowly to comprehend i
couldn't do what everyone else did which
is just
you know read a chapter a night like it
wasn't even a possibility so i had to
figure out how to
read a lot slower for comprehension and
now that i'm reading things that i'm
passionate about
i think that there's a comprehension
that to me is the goal of reading is to
comprehend and then be able to
either apply or teach others there's
nothing else there's no other reason for
it
so
every time that i'm
reading something and i i i read a lot
now
i'm constantly trying to figure out like
do i own this could i talk to somebody
else about this or could i own this in
the business as opposed to
i've
found books that i don't feel like that
with and i realize that i find that the
goal
is to finish the book
and there's a dopamine thing of like
finishing a book like i accomplish
things i get things done and that can't
be the goal
so
i think that that learning aspect of
you the only reason to do this
and probably because like i never
finished a book when i was in high
school
so that wasn't even a goal anyways it
was just like you gotta get some
comprehension out of this and try to
um i think that's kind of
uh given me a little bit more
um
you know i think that that dyslexic is
giving me an advantage um whereas in
school man it was really really
challenging
you know it it's such a big thing in
when your school
at least the way that i went is like
you're you're one of three things like
you're either good-looking and popular
you're an athlete and a jock and a stud
or you're smart and you get yourself
worth out of that thing
and i wasn't super popular i wasn't the
star athlete and i wasn't and man i was
the opposite of what smart was the way
smart was defined in academia which is
hey ben could you read the the next page
to the class out loud
and holy crap
that's my
my my nightmare because stuff the word
would just go fuzzy blank stumbling on
words
um and i would label myself
as
um
not smart
but what i realized
as i
started to get into business was i had a
huge advantage my dad was um also
challenged but incredibly good leader in
business um ceo of multiple different
companies um and then helped take
companies public
and i learned a lot watching him
navigate the workplace both from a
worthy ethic standpoint and how much
common sense business is
i think business is more common sense
than is academic
if you had such a critical inner voice
when you were a kid
how have you got yourself to the stage
now where you're talking about turning
that critic into a coach what have you
done to move your self-talk from what
sounds like a
pretty shitty place yeah to a much more
positive place
so it's
um it's not binary it's uh meaning that
it's not like i was terrible then and
i'm great now yeah right so
um certainly had negative self-talk in
terms of academics and other things
um
then
and i certainly don't have it all
figured out right now
um i still have the inner voice
and continue to work on it um
but the the words that you use there is
exactly the way that i try to reframe it
is coach versus critic
and the critic
sits on the sidelines
doesn't get their hands dirty and just
points out all the faults
i think we all
have
i shouldn't say all a lot of us have
that built into us for any number one of
different reasons right parents teachers
coaches
upbringing whatever it might have been
and i certainly do as well
and i think that's the goal for most of
us is first and foremost become aware of
the voice
50 of people don't even believe that
there's a voice in their head
like that's a that's
staggering to me because as an introvert
that's all i listen to that [ __ ] blows
my mind yeah exactly my the voices in my
set my head sing [ __ ] barbershop
together yeah
exactly so
the first thing is becoming aware of the
voice and then the next one is just an
understanding
that you don't need to try to control it
the awareness on just by itself just the
awareness of that voice
is massive
and that awareness the more you become
aware of it
when you just from the because if you
try to change it you just get frustrated
and you get depressed and you beat
yourself up and the critic comes on top
of the critic
where you go like
um
they don't like what i'm saying right
now and they become aware of that you go
oh my god look at you you're complaining
i'm the sort of person that says they
don't like what i'm saying right now
yeah on you spin on that yeah and this
is where you see people melt down in
public speaking right they're giving a
talk and also they fumble on their words
and they go oh my god you fumbled on
your words you go oh my god you're
fumbling on your words oh my and it's
been so game laid on guilt laid on shame
later on that's actually
to me
that is
the path
awareness and then the next step is
awareness
without judgment
and when you create awareness without
judgment
all of a sudden now you start to realize
the root causes you figure out the
triggers that set those things off
and now what you do is the next time
that happens
you start to realize
how you're pre-programmed we all are
running a script that is pre-programmed
into us from our childhood and it is
guiding our every action decision and
behavior
unnecessarily
it's a faulty script that doesn't
actually exist
but your reality is different than my
reality based off the script that we've
experienced in the programming
meaning
you
um
are walking
down the street and you hear a dog bark
and you grew up with a dog a golden
retriever that was super fuzzy and used
to play with it in the park and to you
a dog barking is a sign of affection
that was your dog used to do before when
you hear you come home and fumble with
the keys they used to bark you go i know
when i open this door my
lovable four-legged friend is going to
give me so much of this feelings of
oxytocin and all the stuff so dog
barking to you
is warm and fuzzies i was bit by a dog
as a kid so i hear dog barking and the
opposite happens anxiety stress the
reality is a dog barking neither one of
those two belief systems are actual
reality but we believe certain realities
only because of our past
when you start to sit quietly and have
awareness of your thoughts
not judging you start to recognize these
triggers
and you start to question them you go
huh
that's just a so you hear a dog bark
i feel a gut thing in my stomach start
to turn and flip upside down
instead of judging it i just go that's
weird
why did that happen
oh
the dog barked that happened the dog's
not going to attack me he's behind a
closed door
like what the heck did that and all of a
sudden you start to melt these paradigms
and you start to be able to navigate
life without these triggers sending you
into these fear loops anxiety loops or
otherwise
now let's bring that to another example
your wife after dinner asks if you can
do the dishes
you grew up with a very very very
controlling mother
and when you wife asked to do that it
sets off a trigger they go freaking wife
trying to control me tell him to do the
dishes like like what no she just asked
you the dishes but you have this program
built into you that when somebody asks
it's a trigger instead when wife asks
you the dishes and you feel that thing
without you just go whoa awareness whoa
that was weird i felt resentment towards
my wife right when she said that
what's the reality of the situation
right now she's just asking if i can do
the dishes she's not trying to control
me that is actually built into me from
my upbringing
it's the programming that i have it's
the software i'm running on
i have the opportunity to rewrite that
software
this is that level of awareness that we
can all navigate life through we don't
need to be the pre-programmed past we
have control over the way we navigate
the future if we bring a level of
awareness and non-judgment to that
present moment
going back to the team thing how do you
get team members to respect the leader
because one thing that i've realized
throughout running businesses is that
the leader often needs to show
degrees of outstanding competence in
order to get respect from the team so we
run nightclubs and we have junior
managers
normal managers senior managers city
managers right
all of the guys that are effective at
being any of the senior levels they have
to be performing well week in week out
and their performance is so transparent
because everyone can see how many
entries they've got into all of our
different events
the the guys that had the most respect
weren't the ones that were the sternest
leaders they weren't the ones that were
even necessarily the best team leaders
they got buy-in from the people below
them because they knew that they had
talent and competence
but
when you get to more complicated
organizations more specialized
decision-making
situations like ceo of a big online
business or coaching a team it's not
your job to be fitter than your athletes
it's your job to be the guy that knows
exactly what to tell them so
how do teams
how do you get team members to respect
the leader and then talk about this sort
of competence dynamic that plays into
that yeah absolutely so confidence is
absolutely one of the pieces
but it's not the only piece and the
reason competence
helps a leader lead is because when
someone shows competence
the people that they're leading
will trust that person more
because
if you show
that you're making the right decisions
and then it things turn out well or you
give some career advice people take it
and then they run with it that just
brings some level of
trust but trust is a three faceted piece
confidence being one of them it's not
the first one
the first thing you have to show it's
the three c's of trust the first one is
showing that you care
because even
the competent leader will not get
everything they can out of them like the
bobby knights the guy that like yells
and screams at his players you know but
doesn't show any sort of level of care
for them whatsoever but he's very
competent he knows the x's and o's of
his sport as well as anybody else will
not get every ounce of potential out of
his athletes or employees or family or
whatever it might be the first thing we
have to show is that we care about
people at an individual basis and this
is why
you know the saying is it takes 40 hours
just to get to past acquaintance level
it takes time
it takes a lot of time to actually get
to the level where somebody goes like i
can trust that person because they care
about me and this is built into our
evolutionary biology
if you were
um a rat you know you were a tribe of
150 that lived around a certain huge
cave and you had campfires you had
certain hunters you had certain warriors
you had certain people that cooked the
food and certain people that tanned the
hides and certain people that took care
of the kids
you needed to know that the person next
to you cared about you
if they didn't care about you no matter
how good of a warrior they were no
matter how good how competent they were
in their skill set it didn't create the
total package because you go like listen
that person's really good when they talk
to me about warrior stuff i'll listen
but i'm not going to turn my back on
that person
it's not total trust
because they might have bigger higher
goals than
they might knock me off so it has to
start with care then the next one is
exactly you said competence you have to
know your stuff you have to be good at
what you do
and the next one is consistency
you have to show up every day you have
to be thr you have to have a through
line just as what you were saying it was
kind of nice having dana white there
that consistency level that just in
itself brings some trust to the
organization because you know that some
of the past is going to be present in
the future is probably fairly stable
because of what they've shown you it's
been consistent if there was a different
leader in place every single year of the
ufc your trust in the ufc would not be
what it is today
so that three-headed monster of care
consistency and trust is how you start
leading groups
then when you're introduced to the
groups that's kind of like the macro
overarching thing
then
there's a step-by-step process to when
you are inserted as the leader and some
people come in and flip over the poker
table and they go this is the way we're
doing it my way the highway and they
totally throw everything and like
that doesn't bring as much trust because
people don't know if you care they don't
know if you're competent and there's no
consistency so what do you do instead
when you come in step one
is you listen
this is what helps introverts and
leadership positions is you don't come
in don't let your ego take over
literally come in even if you are the
most senior position you're the ceo of
the business come in and spend your
first two weeks just listening
listening to people understanding them
what makes them tick understanding their
roles and responsibilities understanding
everything that you possibly can so that
you can step two
learn
listen and learn
if you were in my position what changes
would you make how would you do your job
differently what are you seeing as
inefficiencies what are you seeing as
things that we should be doing going
forward
step three
is help
and help in any which small way
right so
an example of this is um ted lasso
are you familiar ted lasso no who's that
oh my gosh it's a it's a it's a show on
um apple tv he's a coach that comes in
to uh run a english premiere of soccer
league he has no idea what he's doing
but right away he just comes in and the
first what he does is he listens to
people learns what their has people
write down suggestions and one of the
things that people said is like
on this professional soccer team is the
shower pressure sucks in the locker room
so the next day there's better shower
pressure you help you make changes no
matter how small listen
learn
and then help
after you help
then
you lead
what too many leaders do is they come in
with an ego and go i have to establish
myself as the leader i have to tell
people what to do i have to show people
what they're doing wrong and the new
direction we're going and because of
that they haven't taken the necessary
steps to work through this the way our
evolutionary biology does is it's
constantly going
friend or foe friend or foe friend or
foe because if it's foe i need to fight
or flight
only two options i need to either resist
this guy because he might be trying to
take my job
hurt me in any
shape wait for him or get the hell out
of here find a new job
until i feel like he is
friend which is the person that's going
to help me at the campfire
support me and care about me
then i can't lead
you can't lead and by the way this is i
didn't create this george washington's
that is the listen
uh learn help then and only then lead
it's kind of like the same thing with
like mechanics consistency then and only
then intensity
same thing listen
learn help then and only then lead
because if you don't you're gonna have
people following you reluctantly and
that's not a leader that's a positional
leader um i had eddie jones head coach
of england rugby on the show a little
while ago and it turned out that he was
up in newcastle so i went for breakfast
with him i got his email address and
unsolicited just asked him to go for
breakfast the next time we did he told
me this story about first off he told me
a story about sir alex ferguson who was
manchester united's manager for a very
long time maybe 20 years something like
that
and when he first came into the club
there was a lot of turmoil and
he needed to get the players on side
with him quickly so what he did was one
of the players tells this story
separately about how every
game
for the entire rest of the season after
alex had joined
alex had gone up to this player and said
to him you are the most important player
on the pitch it is all about you today
you are the most important player and it
only turned out toward the end of the
season he started chatting to a couple
of the other guys it turned out that
alex had been saying that to every
single one of them love that because he
needed all of them to feel like they had
that bond but he needed to expedite it
he didn't have time to wait to actually
be able to work through stuff and he's
become one of the most successful soccer
coaches of all time
another story that eddie told me so this
guy is in charge of our rugby world cup
hopes right 2023 rugby world cup's
coming around and this is the man who
was coached played for australia coached
australia japan
and england all at separate uh times he
was a
school supply replacement teacher as
well for sport but also taught
everything so he's literally from the
lowest
13 year old boys picking up a rugby ball
for the first time to the best teams on
the planet right he's done the entire
thing
and i was asking him because he's going
to go watch this game afterward i said
so what are you looking for you're going
to go watch these guys there's
whatever 30 people plus some referees
plus some physios it's like 35 people on
the pitch what are you looking for he
said well first off i'm getting rid of
all the noise so i get rid of the
players that i'm not looking at now look
at the players but at least 50 of what
i'm focused on when i'm watching the
players at the game isn't their time
during the game it's how are they
interacting with the coaches during the
warm-up what's their body language like
if the score starts to go in there in
that direction or if it's if the game
starts to go against them do they keep
their head down or they keep their head
up he told me another story about when
he took over the japanese team and japan
wasn't particularly good at rugby
asian men uh typically aren't built for
that sort of a sport especially if you
put up up against what like pacific
island is like a samoan versus a
japanese guy typically you're gonna get
flattened by the samoan um so he was
trying to make them fast and do other
bits and pieces and one of the lessons
that he was looking for um
in when he observes the players is how
much they look at the coaches he says
that he wants players that take the game
plan and then they work for themselves
and he'd spoken to
apparently japan's good at
three things
um women's volleyball
like women's downhill skiing
and something else right so he went to
go and speak to the women's volleyball
coach and i didn't know this because i
haven't watched that much volleyball but
apparently the coaches from volleyball
are right on the side of the court so
they're right next to the players
and the coach came in he didn't take
your softly softly approach he took a
slightly he took the flip the poker
table uh over approach
and he watched the game
and the players that kept looking to him
during the match
all of them were binned all of them went
and he said i want players that can play
for themselves and now eddie's taking
that forward so he's watching this game
and maybe there's two or three players
on the pitch on a match that he's
looking at and he's looking at what's
their body language like before they
begin how are they interacting with the
rest of the staff how are they warming
up are they doing it with enthusiasm are
they looking like they're positive
what's their body language like if they
start to win or if they start to lose
and how much are they able to focus on
their own game or how much are they
looking at the coach
for the equivalent of audibles and plays
and to hear that from
one of the most respected sports coaches
on the planet was that was [ __ ] a
good breakfast
super cool love those stories it's
you know one of the sayings is you're
not a leader
until you've created a leader
that has created a leader
because what we're trying to do is
empower people that's real i mean
otherwise what you do is you're a micro
manager and to the to the case in point
of what those coaches on the atlantic
fields we're looking for is they need
people that can go and
lead others and leave themselves and
lead others and that's super cool
empowerment is
um
you know i believe it's a it's one of
the biggest traits that anybody can have
as a leader
is get people that are smarter in the
room than they are and empower them to
make decisions and lead themselves
i i also really like the
you know the coach that was not
necessarily just looking at the players
playing but the players because
you know their body language what are
they how are they interacting with each
other
you know i
that's what i look for when i'm coaching
my athletes a ton is
i i
you're giving me words to this but
about 50
is execution right it's
um how efficient are they being with the
movements how are they cycling a barbell
is there muscle up transition smooth
all the rest
but the other 50
is
what i'll call
vibe
and it is the intangibles and it is um
how are they
handling themselves when they're walking
on the floor when they're walking off
the floor when they're setting the
barbells up
when
um they're between rounds like there's
so much to be gleaned and gained from
awareness
of that aspect of coaching as well and i
believe it translates really well
to
an organization and business
because part of what we do
about 50
is the actual x's and o's you know
are we producing the widgets are the
widgets up to the standards of
expectations
but the other 50 percent is how do
people interact as a team and
the whole kind of
vibe aspect of this
and in the the recent book that i wrote
i speak to this
and i got it from
the guys that own 11 madison park which
is a restaurant in new york city they
got voted as the best restaurant in the
world
and there's the back of the house and
there's the front of the house the back
of the house is where the chefs are and
um dishwashers and all that then there's
the front of the house where the um the
servers are and the
concierge and all the rest
and the guy that's in charge of the
front of the house
that's a your experience it's not just
about the quality of the food it's about
the experience of the whole thing i
think restaurants are just such amazing
businesses to
to dissect
because they kind of have everything
they have product they have service they
have
um
this
you're only in there for a short period
of time you if no one decides to come to
the restaurant that day
they go out a bit it's like it's wild to
me it's not like a the safety of an
annuity like a subscription service or
something else so
but the
the guy that owns the place and the
guy's in front of the front of the
charge in charge of the front of the
house
he would um what i call soft eyes where
he would just go
to a corner of the restaurant
sort of close his eyes but not
completely
and just
listen
and the way he said it was you can just
feel when it's a good night
there's a certain
excitement in the air
and
i think that translates to managing any
team
i'm a big believer
in
becoming really good
at having good meetings
because i think that having a good
meeting is essentially
that to me is the team actually
performing
and
you want to
as a leader it's very important
to
get your team
to actually be good at being
good at meetings and it sounds weird
because what everyone thinks their job
is to be good at their job
but
if you have a whole bunch of star
performers there's i mean there are so
many examples of teams with multiple
all-stars on them that way underperform
what you actually need is a good team
and when your team truly comes together
is in meetings and
i think that that is a massively under
utilized aspect because i think that um
poorer leaders do it in a very
transactional way where they think the
goal is for to get you know
me to tell everyone here what's
happening
and as long as that happens
the meeting was a success
and that's not the case the case of
meeting is to get people to feel
empowered
and to get people to feel connected to
the overall vision and direction of the
organization
and that is one of the ways that we can
do that is by with the
the soft eyes
the empowering and just get the feel
of how are we working together as a team
that's expertise that's the role of the
leader right the the guy at the top of
the guy is at the top
their job is to be a hard to replicate
complex decision engine they can't
precisely tell you all of the things
that they've taken in but they aggregate
all of the different stuff so i'm sure
that you did the same but when i'm
running a club night i don't want to be
near the front door i want to be 30
yards away from the front door and i can
see
where the guys that are scanning tickets
aren't leaving gaps for people to move
through i can see where we're getting
held up with the door staff at the front
i can see that the smoking area is
encroaching and that the barriers have
changed i can see that there's that
group of guys over there that aren't
going to get because they don't have
student id but if we let them wait and
they get to the front they're going to
be pissed off because they've just
waited for 20 minutes but the cue pick
of the guy's job it is he hasn't seen
them all of this stuff happens the same
as you in your gym i i imagine if you
want to get a feel for how the class is
going you don't stand in the middle of
the class you stand
right at the very very far edge and you
just that softer eyes open gaze you're
just looking across the entire gym and
that's where
that that's one of the beautiful things
that's why i or anyone would enjoy
watching someone in flow at something
that they're great at i would enjoy
watching you
watching your gym
i would enjoy watching the guy that runs
the front of house of that fancy
restaurant
observing his restaurant because you're
seeing someone aggregate
millions of bits of data
and then come just come up with
one thing
the one thing that's going to have the
highest impact okay where is it that
that q that group of guys that smoking
area that cue from the coach that fact
that the person over the far side is the
one person that hasn't yet been spoken
to by any of the guys that look whatever
it is right that table that we know that
hasn't had the wine whatever whatever it
might be
like that's [ __ ] awesome to see i
nerd out over expertise like that so
much i think it's amazing to see people
that have that level of competence
yeah i love that that's uh
it's it's so
i love what you're saying is like
computing like the millions of data
points all together and if you ask
somebody to break that down you can't
you just have to you just
know it intuitively because it's been
built into you from so many it's kind of
like the the expert
the the fire chief right the fire chief
is in the building they're all fighting
the fires and without any he just goes
guys let's go get out of here yep
exactly there's he can't point to
anything he's just feeling there's loads
of stories like that from 911 as well
exactly the same thing there's so many
stories like that and it's what you were
saying is
i can just tell that those guys with
this those are students they're not
going to their doc and we got to make
sure that we're not it's
it's it's it's a built into you and
that's what the level of that's the
confidence piece that's where you you
you get to display your level of
expertise
who is one of the athletes that's had
the best vibe
that you've worked with is there someone
that you put them in the gym and
everybody else just gets in a better
mood everyone's on a a good level
yeah catrin definitely
catrin's like
phenomenal catrin is
um
you know but she wasn't always like that
katrin used to be kind of an emotional
uh when she was first starting off as a
competitor in our sport um but katrin is
awesome katrin is
um
a fierce competitor but also
makes everyone feel
um
feel good about things i think you've
mentioned in the past that her and your
wife are kind of similar apparently like
girly and giggly and they get excited
about stuff and you're a bit more
sort of reserved
british sort of standoffish
type thing and um you you're so right
that that vibe element of having having
a a katrin or a mrs bergeron or whatever
like in the team
especially if you have a male dominated
team
[ __ ] it is so
important to have someone that just
brings a bit of lightness and and
fun
and energy to the situation that isn't
this super intensity that i think a lot
of guys try and fix men try and fix
situations by drilling down into focus
more by trying to grip things harder and
that often takes you further away from
flow rather than into it it adds
pressure on as opposed to releasing it
and i think yeah having having those
sorts of uh characters makes a big
difference
absolutely yeah i love the the the
references to a flow state because
whether it's my athletes or my employees
my team
that's the goal right that is where
the best of you
comes out it literally flows out of you
because it's not being interrupted by
that
the logical thinking brain which is slow
and too calculated
you could you know that
um whether it's you uh putting on the
nightclub or the restaurateur or the
fire chief
that's that's just something that comes
and oozes out of them
and
having people that keep it
um not so heavy
uh
for sure is an asset
a quote from you that says the harder
you try the more elusive flow is
and yeah [ __ ] man if that's not true but
there's a there's a real
difficulty there's like a bar of soap
that you're trying to grab and like it's
like this
yeah like oh i gotta and the more you
try to like focus the more you try to
focus on how to grab the the harder it
gets
there's a tension here though
between
balancing desire and grit and effort
with
ease
and presence and intuition and good and
especially i imagine in a sport but also
especially in something like podcasting
is a good example
if you try really really hard you end up
being [ __ ] like the goal is
to just ease yourself into it how do you
encourage a team especially in a sport
that is reliant on
grit determination resilience digging
your heels in getting serious about the
lift getting serious about the workout
how do you balance that grit and effort
with ease and presence
okay so the
the number one thing that pulls people
out of a flow state is a distraction
so it makes sense right you're you're
plugging away you're writing your your
beautiful manuscripts you're
um you're you're shooting baskets and
everything's falling you're
um doing whatever it is that you you do
you and things are it's amazing but then
a car horn goes off or somebody um
punches you in the the back or
um somebody turns the temperature up to
uh or someone throws water on your face
like like those distractions are gonna
pull you out of a flow state
those are not the common distractions
the common distractions are the voice in
your head
that's the distraction that we most of
us are fighting and that distraction is
throwing things forward
what are the consequences of my actions
right now
that's usually what pulls people out of
a flow state so they get too caught up
in what they're doing right now and
they're thinking about it too much
so
imagine an athlete
that you that is about to take the
game-winning shot in a basketball game
and he's going okay if i make this shot
that means
bigger sponsorships more uh bigger
contract everyone's gonna love me if i
miss this shot holy crap the whole
team's gonna i'm being tasked with this
that all of that is if once that starts
you're out of flow you're go it's it's
gone it's a bar of soap that you can not
grab onto the more you try the harder it
is
so it has to be
this trained level of
being present
and this is where like mindfulness has
become so popular in sports because what
mindfulness is is the ability to stay
present
open-minded without judgment
what that means is it allows you it
doesn't going to put you but it allows
for a flow state
if any one of those three things doesn't
happen if you're not open-minded you're
close-minded that's a
that's antagonistic to a flow state if
you're not positive you're negative
going like oh this is going to [ __ ]
suck this is going to be terrible i'm
going to miss this shot
you're out and you're judging okay what
is this going to be good or it's going
to be bad
michael jordan was able to get a flow
state more than anybody else in his
sport he goes why would i worry about
taking a shot i haven't even taken yet
so he doesn't worry about anything
because once he's not going to worry
about taking a shot before he takes it
because
why would you ever worry about that he
takes it why is he going to judge what
it's gone it's already happened it's in
the past so he's just constant it's
literally the ability to stay in the
here and now
and that's way easier said than done
that is a massive challenge
we have this infatuation right now in
society with being present
and it's because people are consumed
with their phones and when you're
consuming the phone your head is in the
screen you're not actually experiencing
life where your feet are
well that's like
the lowest level of presence
there are so many different levels of
being present and the highest level of
presence
is actually pure consciousness
where you are just operating in a flow
state which is again
living with pure enlightenment and joy
and there is no good or bad as
shakespeare said there is no good or bad
but thinking makes it so so stop your
[ __ ] thinking and just experience the
moment now
if we could shut our brains off as
athletes we could experience
everything that we have the potential to
experience which is so beyond our
wildest dreams it is the
the middle aged woman lifting the car
off of her baby that is like what we are
capable of but we don't do that because
we put these self regulators these
invisible ceilings limitations on us
that keep us from operating at our
fullest potential
our fullest potential is us in a flow
state
and we've all experienced it at certain
times in our lives one way or another
it's either
you running your nightclubs and it's
like it's just going are you doing a
podcast or your ted talk and it's just
flowing out
other people have done it when they're
composing music or skiing in powder or
um they're swimming and all of a sudden
they feel like they're there's no effort
they can breathe it's like we've all had
these little glimpses of it
what the
the thing that we are all aspiring to do
is to live in a perpetual state
of flow
pure consciousness finding god heaven on
earth whatever that thing is
our true best selves
and that's why i believe that athletics
is such a powerful tool for us to become
our best selves
because he can show us what those flow
states look like
one of the interesting things that
stephen cutler said i know you're a fan
of his work as well he's been on your
show on mine and he talks about the fact
that emotion knocks us out of flow
as easily as anything else or in fact
even more easily so task switching you
switch from doing one thing to another
it takes you about 20 minutes to go back
in flow is precisely the same and he
said that an emotion if you have an
emotion arise and this is one of the
problems with if you're trying to write
a manuscript or a blog post or an
article or an email or something and you
still have your notifications on and
something pops up and it's good or bad
or whatever
that's just kicked you out to flow for
20 minutes
and there's something
this is something that i'm playing
around with more that an embodied
practice
like
a crossfit like a
bike ride like a brazilian jiu jitsu a
boxing or whatever yoga pilates [ __ ]
tai chi
there's something
to me easier to drop into flow when i'm
doing something physical than when i'm
doing something mental
because i'm able to
the goal is to switch the mind off but
when you're doing something that
requires a ton of cognition you're
switching the mind on to switch the mind
off and it kind of can it feels to me
more difficult um but there's a
a virtual reality shooting range bar in
the city where i live and
one of their games that they have is
about two minutes long
five different targets pop up every
three seconds you have to hit them so
you go like ding ding ding ding ding and
then it'll change again
i swear to god that is the quickest way
to get into a flow state one of the guys
stopped doing it and he turned around
and he said dude you could have told me
that my mother had died halfway through
me doing that and i wouldn't have
registered what you'd said so there's
something about a physical activity and
that's why i think
sports and pursuits like crossfit where
you have a class where you've kind of
externalized the thinking brain to the
coach coach is telling you what to do
you don't need to think oh well is it 21
reps or should i maybe actually do only
at 15 so i'm feeling a bit tight it's
like no the workout says it's 21. so you
do 21.
all of that externalizing all of that
physicality i think that that
especially after the last two years
people have probably forgotten the fact
that a physical pursuit like that is
just it's inherently fulfilling forget
the health benefits the longevity the
musculature the leanness all that stuff
it's inherently fulfilling because you
get out of your head for
45 minutes or 60 minutes of the day
yeah absolutely i couldn't
i could agree with that more um
i think that part of that the
physicality part um is also though
because you're an athlete
and because
you inherently
um enjoy it
whereas somebody else is getting off the
couch for the first time
they're they're trying to do something
physical and their their inner voice is
just screaming at them because they're
full of
i don't fit in here you're never going
to achieve this this
and that's why i think that certain
people
find it in their own ways
and some people sitting down
just writing oh [ __ ] for some people it
will be music if you put me in front of
it put me down
piano
so that's why people get addicted to
this performance thing of music like
music is so
because it gets people into a flow state
it's
it's just a
especially performing it listening to it
is one thing but if you're performing
music
i can't imagine the feeling of
performing music in front of like
tens of thousands of people that to me
would just be like
the ultimate well you feel that you feel
like even from the crowd
yes you go to a huge concert and
you feel this it's called collective
effervescence in the social psychology
literature
you don't know the person that's 50
yards in front of you and yet you're
moving in the same way and yet you're
thinking the same sort of things and
your emotions are working in resonance
and this isn't some [ __ ] magnetic woo
ronda burn the secret field [ __ ] this is
you and them are emotionally in the same
sort of state because of what you're
observing on stage and what you're
observing on stage is a musician in flow
performing something which is toward the
limit of their capacity
and it's beautiful and
terrifying and awe-inspiring and
dread-inspiring all at the same time and
everyone moves together
no one's nobody outside said right guys
so we're all going to do this dance move
at this point so why the [ __ ] did
everybody coordinate well because
everybody's in the same place
that's super cool
yeah it's uh
which
i get what caller's saying in terms of
like emotion is a fast way to knock you
out of it but
i i might caveat that with
certain emotions
anxiety fear
dread
judgment yes but feelings of elation
love
connectedness those are emotions too
and
um you know the biggest wave surfers in
the world feel connected to the wave if
we say feel connected feel is an emotion
what they're not is judging am i going
to survive this thing
what they're not doing it's like you
know
climbing so the free solo el capitan
like total flow state at one with the
wall all of a sudden this thing he
struggled with for months and months and
months became
if not effortless like enjoyable right
it was like there's this level of
enjoyment is a feeling and in flow state
there is a feelings of enjoyment so
if there is nothing will knock you out
of a flow state faster than a negative
emotion that might have actually been
what he said i mean i just misquoted him
there yeah so i think that that's a big
level of awareness because we want
people
um feeling the vibe because the vibe is
the is is so key to that
talking about katrin and the guys you've
had some big changes recently you've had
some coaches and some big name athletes
that have moved on how do you manage a
period of turbulent change like that
so the first recognition is that change
is inevitable it's it's it's it's part
of
um
our world in our universe we start
whether you believe that we started as a
pin-sized thing that exploded and now
we're this universe so you believe that
we are adam and eve or you believe that
we you know crawled out of the oceans
grew legs and like change is and it's
the only constant is change
so
that's one of the the big aspects of
that um and then the next is just
perspective
so um one of the one things you're
alluding to is catrin who's the athlete
that i trained that won the crossfit
games a couple times um
super close looked at her as like
above a best friend almost like a
daughter lived with us for years and
years and years uh recently decided to
move back to iceland
so the perspective there is if you don't
take perspective you go like oh my god i
can't believe this is happening
what do you mean we had such a good
thing going like
but the pers the reality in the
perspective is
like oh my gosh what how amazing was
this i can't believe that you gave up
the last seven years of your life to
leave your family in iceland to move and
live and train with me in boston what an
amazing awesome experience that i am so
grateful for
it also makes total sense that you won't
go back to boston you are now
20
you know
eight years old your life is happening
you have a real meaningful relationship
with a significant other you bought an
apartment
a couple years ago that you have yet to
have the opportunity to live in you're
getting a dog your sister is having
babies your best friends are having
babies and getting married i understand
like
so it's perspective
of understanding where we are and
it would be once you put it in that
through that lens it actually kind of
sounds ridiculous to think anything
otherwise so to me
you know i i think of that and we talked
to started the conversation off with
those
three
um pillars of awareness intention and
action i like to put all of those with
the prism of perspective on top of all
of it
we can't get wrapped up in our own
little tiny little worlds
it is something is bigger than us
and
we
we like to have the entire world operate
the way that we want it to
and if things don't go our ways we get
all bent out of shape
well that's kind of ridiculous there's
7.5 billion people on planet earth
and in our little world we want everyone
to act think and behave exactly like we
want them to and if they don't we get
all bent out of shape
to the tiniest little things of like
someone said something about you on
social media to
you show up to a party and someone's
wearing the same things as you to
someone that was close to you decides to
move away like
this is the reality of the world like
nothing we have is going to line up
exactly the way we want it to
whether even if you're a tree it's going
to be windier than you want colder than
you want and rain more than you want or
it might be too sunny longer than you
want you're not getting enough rain but
no one experiences no one no thing
experiences life on their terms
you don't you don't have that much
control and i like i think that we think
that we have more control than we do and
when you allow yourself the opportunity
to just let go of those things that you
don't control man it's a whole lot
easier to navigate these challenges and
these changes in our lives
is it not hard to feel fear or
self-doubt or whatever when you've got
that turbulence going on or are you able
to bypass that with perspective you know
so
if you had asked if um like catrin
leaving if that had happened six years
ago i probably it probably would have
been pretty
a pretty darn big moment
and not in a good way
um
i think i've been able to kind of
navigate the world through this
prism for a little while of a
perspective
even
still it's not like
sunshine rainbows brick paved road going
forward it's still like gosh
dang like that would instill cool
but
that's pretty darn short i can so for an
example
when catherine told me
um she was in iceland at the time she
always went back to iceland after the
games she went to iceland and the the
conversation i was having with her was
um on the phone i was at my daughter's
um my daughter plays collegiate lacrosse
i was at her college lacrosse game
between games called katrin scheduled a
call and was like um we're just talking
about
and
we were talking about when you're coming
back and she's like
you know i think i might stay
and
i
the initial gut reaction wasn't one of
like what was me it was not
what he it was not of question it was
which i'm really proud of honestly this
because this is something that's been
um
it was
um gratitude it was gratitude for having
had the opportunity
and that was i i was like i actually
hung up the phone
um
went and talked to
my wife i didn't tell my daughter my
daughter's incredibly close to um katrin
um because i didn't want to affect her
next game but after my daughter left
for
her next game i just said um catcher's
gonna stay in iceland i'm not gonna work
with her as a coach anymore
um
and she said how do you feel and i was
like i'm totally okay with this
and she's like i'm not surprised because
we've been working on this for a long
time we've done a lot of
self-exploration a lot of spiritual
journey a lot of meditating a lot of
personal growth
um to where something that would have
rocked me five years ago
um
was uh a bump not a rock
now having said that there was still
angst when we were what's funny is i
know i'm not enlightened or anything
close to that yet because when we
decided to announce this to people
um
i got the feelings and it's that was
weird to me is like
i still got the feelings of like that
gut feeling that that uneasy feeling of
like you're about to go on and give a
presentation that you're not prepared
for
that like oh this is this sucks type
thing
so what do you think so why do you think
that is what do you think that's about
great question judgment i'm so fearful
of judgment of other people
yeah i'm not there
um
i'm more at peace with my own who i am
as a person
but i'm still not there where i don't
give a crap about what other people
think yet and i go back and forth on
that a little bit you know they they say
like
you should you know
when you're completely enlightened you
shouldn't let the opinions of other
people affect you whatsoever and i know
i'm not there yet because i don't
believe that i honestly don't believe it
so i have a lot of either a lot of
growth to do or that's just not the case
because
um i think that's
if i
you know i don't i don't i don't feel
like i need to justify myself along the
way
every single step i take
but
i do believe that uh
i should say i believe what people's
other other people's opinions still
matter to me
i'm just not a total grown up yet
dude bypassing that
limbic system
is
superhuman
you know being able to not track
whatever it is whatever the system is
that your brain thinks is being
activated there whether it's the
potential falling status whether it's
the whatever the concerns are around
other people's impressions of you
this is
driven into us
millions and millions of years of
evolution i mean what is it that people
say heights and public speaking are two
of the greatest fears that humans have
you think well yeah one's a mortal
threat the other one's just awkward but
why is it that that's the case well it's
because the eyes of the tribe being on
you and if you fail then you're going to
fall in their standing and that survival
that's reproduction man like to to get
past that to be able to
front brain think your way
out of the thing that gate keeps all of
your thoughts to the rest of your body
is
when you get there let me know like
because yeah that's what that's what i
think we shall be striving for
you know because that's flow what's
happened is i should be living my life
in
pure
consciousness pure
here's
what i think we shall be shooting for we
should all be shooting for unconditional
happiness
now that word unconditional
when i first came across it
floored me
unconditional means
without condition regardless no matter
what so if i ask you chris do you want
to be happy
you're going to say everyone's going to
respond yes
and i say are you willing to be happy
no matter what and you go
yes and i go that means
even if
your
you your your wife tries to stab you
you are gonna you love her no difference
even if
you lose everything every single person
that you've ever come in contact with
says chris is a bad person
like even if
um you're outside you forgot your jacket
it starts pouring rain
and you go like whoa whoa like well i'm
going to be happy but not if i lose my
job not if i lose my wife not if i get
cancer and now you're putting conditions
on it
and what we should all be aspiring to
is
unconditional and just slowly
eliminating the conditions so
there are certain things now that don't
bug me that used to bug me
right
um
someone's saying something about me on
social media doesn't really bug me that
much anymore
um but
catrin saying something about me would
bug me
so i'm not we're not quite there yet
and that's where if we can get there
that's unconditional and that is
enlightened and that's where the monks
are right that's where
but the best thing is to not have to go
into a monastery wear a robe and
meditate for 20 hours a day to get there
you won't be able to find that while
still navigating everyday life being a
father of four running a business
driving in traffic
and you know going to um kids birthday
parties on the weekends
when you can do it in that state
that to me is
the jam that is the thing that we shall
be shooting for
and
it takes awareness intentionality and
action to get there
write the [ __ ] book man i'm telling
you right the
write the book the world needs it uh ben
bergeron ladies and gentlemen uh new
book unlocking potential will be linked
in the show notes below
where else should people go if they want
to keep up to date with what you do
uh probably the easiest place is
instagram just at ben bergeron
um
and then
uh
if people want to
uh jump on the book it's on amazon and
um
comp train is the training platform so
um in the uh apple store
um
com uh comp train
and live life chasing excellence podcast
shout out patrick
here we go in a podcast
ben it's always a pleasure man i really
really appreciate you coming on
appreciate it chris thank you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace
you